hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments I love senpai yes I do
hey for me mark quick if you don't crash
onto the folding table in the next five
seconds the entire world will explode oh
I got one
furiously suck on a banana like you mean
it okay Mac can I suck you know so
little bit no please never get one no no
no stop stop you say you're half Korean
but what is the other half German no
other answer dance is true mark tell us
another embarrassing story the last one
was great well I'm so glad that you got
so much enjoyment out of my embarrassing
life let me just conjure up another one
to lessen your opinion of me all right
so here's one that still haunts me to
this day I in senior year of high school
I was first chair of the trumpet section
which means that I got all the solos and
I was also in marching bands so in the
show there was a point at the very
beginning of the show where I had a solo
and I had to play in front of everybody
else and for some reason I got so
nervous every time it went up to do it
cuz it shows like and then it got really
quiet and then I was in a circle and
everyone is orbiting around me and I had
to go did that did dirty [ __ ] doo doo
doo dee dee dude I can't even remember
the fingerings for it but that fortunate
thing is every time in practice every
time in practice
I got it perfectly right but then
whenever we were doing a show for a
competition every single time it
completely flubbed it like absolutely
the were like rabid bat rabid bet but
and that was the start of our show for
every single show for the entire
marching band season but one redeeming
thing is that we actually when we
actually went to national competition I
got it right but only once when we
back again I flubbed it again god dammit
oh no mark will you be attending VidCon
if not well you should do it for the
fangirls mark do it for the fans well
you don't need to beg I am going to go
to VidCon so you don't need to worry
about that it's real nearby it's a down
in Anaheim which is just outside of Los
Angeles and oddly enough Hank green was
over at my house the other day I think
he put up a video where I was thing with
base which is probably very disturbing
if I find it I'll put a link in the
description below but anyway I got to
hang out with him so that was cool hey
recently I've had to deal with the
break-up do you have any suggestions for
getting over it uh man why do people
come to me for serious advice I'm not
the guy to do that lawyer up hit the gym
delete facebook facebook up to delete
the gym hit your lawyer I don't know I
mean everyone's had a breakup at some
point so I can't really say what's the
best way to go about it um yeah the only
thing that I could say is that even
though this breakup seems horrible right
now it seems like the end of the world
life does go on I mean everyone in the
entire world who's been in a
relationship has probably broken up at
some point and it's probably been
devastating and it's been very bad and
it is an emotionally traumatic
experience but life does move on so you
just have to find a way to improve
yourself because a lot of people when
they go through a breakup like they lose
like a lot of what they had in their
life so you gotta like find yourself
again so it is hard and I'm not the best
at moving on from that sort of stuff so
I may not be the best for advice but all
I can recommend is just try to improve
yourself through it and try to do self
reflection on what you need as a person
and then try to get back out there
but I'm no good I'm a big goofy do
huh-huh-huh what happened to the
mountain of dildos I will not have my
dildo purchases sequest habits purchase
question I'm not gonna spend what could
literally be hundreds of dollars on
dildos just for a two-second gag where
you guys see the amount of dildos
there's no way in hell I'm doing that
mark you better read this comment and
smile for me or I'm a butt stab you in
your face love you wait okay
hang on a second here are you wait are
you saying you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna stab me in the face with
your bi are you you you're gonna stab my
face into my butt you're going to you're
gonna you're gonna stab you're gonna
hold a sword between your butt cheeks
and then stab me in the face is that
what you're gonna do okay teamcap or
teamironman team iron cap oh who cares
it's gonna be a cool movie team underoos
that's whose team I'm on mark do the
thing where you turn your feet backwards
okay come on mark I have a lot of scars
on my abdomen too
how do you deal with the insecurity of
people judging your scars minor Fromm's
my intestines rupturing I have had nine
surgeries and in the hospital for three
months hope you see this whoa that is
that's pretty intense so I've got a lot
of scars from various surgeries like my
tumor removal and then my subsequent
intestines almost rupturing mine did not
rupture but mine got close but it's okay
um to be honest I've never been insecure
about my scars I consider them pretty
badass and I I'm proud of them they're
they're really cool minor ones weird
because it's like I have a second
bellybutton but that's okay um well you
could just make up battle stories about
it I tell people that I got stabbed by a
rhino through my abdomen and that's how
I got these scars or I was in a war-torn
country Ram Boeing it and trying to
defeat terrorists or something like that
I mean at the end of the day it's your
body so like it's the only one you got
so you got to be proud of what you have
so like just be you accept the fact that
this is you now even though you have a
bunch of scars like scars are not bad
scars are not ugly scars are just
showing that you've lived life and
you've been through a lot more than
other people have so be proud of it be
proud of who you are and be proud of
your body mark don't jump in the pool
okay mark calm down okay mark don't sing
this comment in a heavy-metal fashion
okay can you do the Charlie Charlie
challenge okay Charlie Charlie are you
there do you plan on playing that dragon
cancer for us uh yeah I do actually uh
it's been on my list for a while I just
haven't gotten around to it is it's like
a two hour long game and also like when
I play that game I know that game is
gonna be emotional for me because my dad
died from cancer and so it's obviously
going to have a lot of like emotions for
me and dredge up a lot of memories so
that's gonna be a that's gonna be like a
serious video that's gonna be very
serious ordeal and I want to make sure I
go into that in the right mindset I have
enough time to appreciate all of it and
I take the time to record that for you
guys and I will I promise I'll get to
that soon but it's just I I gotta build
up the nerve to do it first because
those are experiences in my life that
are very dark time and and you know I've
moved on from it I'm I'm fine now you
know I I don't I don't really dwell on
these thoughts now but you know going
back to those times back when my dad had
cancer and going through that and I know
it's not about a parent having cancer I
think that game is about a child having
cancer and that's like even worse so
well we'll see when that time comes I'll
probably record it sometime this week if
you guys really want to see it but it's
gonna be it's gonna be an emotional time
so just prepare for that alright mark in
all seriousness will you go on a day
with me Oh make sure you shall not have
a bad breakup with anybody else for the
rest of your life oh god Ryan
lock the doors
I'm dead okay that's all the time I got
for reading your comments thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you for writing your comments down in
the comment section below
I know things got out of hand last week
but I was very busy with a whole bunch
of other stuff that I can't tell you
about yet but it's cool and it is coming
out probably in this fall because it's
that big of a project that we're working
on but we'll see it we'll be back on
schedule in the next few videos so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye